lorsqu'on voulait faire en soutenant
romain Verlet parce que c'est une
enquête de 18 mois et que c'est vraiment
un journaliste qui a dédié à ses 18
derniers mois à cette enquête incroyable
en ayant une centaine d'entretiens il y
a eu une omerta qui était incroyable
donc il s'est vraiment battu comme comme
un tigre c'était de mettre au jour le
système PPDA et de montrer à quel point
il y avait eu une omerta terrible de la
part de TF1 en tout cas de beaucoup de
gens de TF1 que beaucoup savaient
préféré se taire et parce qu'on touchait
pas à l'icône du 20h parce que c'était
une star incroyable PPDA non seulement
c'était l'icône du 20h mais c'était
également celui qui faisait des faisait
les carrières
littéraires parce qu'il tenait les
émissions littéraires donc c'était le
chouchou aussi des éditeurs c'était
notre chouchou à nous parce qu'on savait
que si un livre était dans une de ses
émissions et bien c'était le succès
assuré donc c'est vrai qu'au fond il a
joui de beaucoup de de complaisance de
la part du petit monde en fait des
médias de l'édition etc non mais c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que aujourd'hui en
fait c'est un peu Lenti Hanouna c'est
c'est vrai tout le monde en disait du
bien non mais c'est vrai c'est ce qu'il
avait la carte en fait il avait la carte
tout le monde disait c'est vrai que
voilà non mais tu es puissant oui mais
voilà mais on peut sur ne pas avoir la
carte hein puissant il était vénéré
c'est-à-dire que c'est ça non mais il
avait la carte parce que c'est un
intellectuel aussi considéré comme un
intellectuel est-ce que vous avez hésité
à publier le livre non j'ai pas hésité à
publier le livre parce que comme vous me
connaissez un peu Cyril j'hésite
rarement quand il s'agit de mettre au
jour une vérité donc mais par contre
effectivement si vous voulez me dire
est-ce que c'est beaucoup d'emmerdes en
perspective une enquête de 100 genre oui
effectivement parce que on sait très
bien que il va y avoir beaucoup de
relectures d'avocats parce que
d'ailleurs on attendait plutôt un procès
de PPDA qu'un procès de la part d'une
d'une plaignante
Gilles c'est donc deux plaignants qui
ont voulu interdire le livre
pour faire interdire le livre et là elle
a perdu et en fait elle se sentait
dépossédée de sa parole c'est à dire que
elle s'était exprimée mais elle n'avait
pas avec l'auteur un accord pour que son
témoignage soit publié etc donc en
justice française c'est très rare
d'avoir l'interdiction d'un livre et
elle a été déboutée voilà alors elle a
pas demandé l'interdiction du livre La
demander la suppression de certains
extraits la concernant notamment les
détails du viol Bernard une fois qu'un
livre est imprimé
quand même au courant demander le
retrait de passage ça veut dire mettre
au pilon une quantité invraisemblable
donc supprimer bien sûr sortie du livre
Bernard la raison Julie oui la raison si
vous voulez quand on est attaqué au
référé on a reçu moi chercher un coup de
fil de l'huissier à 19h30 me disant
j'avais jusqu'à 20h pour prendre le
référé je l'ai pris j'ai fait face
j'étais là le lendemain à 14h avec mon
auteur devant la 17e chambre bien sûr
quand on vous appelle la veille et que
c'est le jour pour le lendemain enfin on
n'a pas 20000 bouquins dans la nature
avec du Tipp-Ex bouquin par bouquin donc
effectivement on ramène tous les
bouquins les pylônes et entre le prix de
faire revenir les bouquins et de les
pilonner il est évident que c'est en
fait la mise à mort du livre et donc la
mise à mort d'une enquête de 18 mois et
moi je vais vous dire un truc si elle
avait gagné ça aurait été problématique
à deux à deux égards 1 la grande le
grand victorieux de cette affaire ça
aurait été PPA parce que cette enquête
elle est très forte c'est 400 pages dans
le cadre pour démonter le système PPDA
et toutes les connivences qui ont été
faites autour de ce personnage et par
ailleurs la deuxième grande défaite ça
aurait été pour le journalisme et le
journalisme d'investigation parce que si
vous voulez qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire aujourd'hui qu'au fond sous
prétexte du respect de la vie privée
parce que c'était ça les deux heures
d'audience du respect de la vie privée
en fait il y a plus de liberté
d'investigation et c'est quand même un
vrai problème parce que là si vous
voulez le respect de la vie privée les
victimes c'est au fond x témoignages de
victimes qui vous raconte leur douleur
c'est incroyablement courageux de mais
du coup ça en fait l'affaire des
victimes comme si c'était pas la nôtre
en fait c'est la faire des victimes
elles ont été violées ça doit rester
l'affaire des victimes non c'est notre
affaire la faire PPDA c'est notre
affaire à tous c'est un système qu'on a
tous cautionné on était tous comme vous
l'avez dit très bien Cyril admirative de
vent ce prince puisqu'on l'a appelé le
Prince Noir le livre exprès ce prince du
20h on admirait sa vie on admirait ses
incartables on le regardait comment dire
tous les soirs on le voyait en Une de
Paris Match c'était une star tout le
monde l'adorait il montait les marches
de Cannes voilà on suivait sa vie intime
en tout cas ce qu'on croyait de ça vient
intime celle qui nous donnait à voir
sauf que il avait en fait une espèce de
Modus opéra indice c'est pour ça qu'on a
mis ce témoignage à moi du sopéra dit où
les femmes il les il les invité après le
20h et il est violet dans son bureau qui
permet à clé et à chaque fois c'était la
même chose elle venait elles étaient
admiratives face à ce personnage elles
arrivaient face à lui et en quelques
secondes il se transformait en prédateur
et il est violet donc si vous voulez on
sait pas amusé par voyeurisme à mettre
au jour ces témoignages on a voulu en
fait mettre au jour un modus opérindique
d'un violeur qui a eu grâce à des
connivences grâce à l'omerta du milieu
au fond la tranquillité totale pendant
des années et pourquoi un certain nombre
de femmes qui ont subi ces violences qui
sont terribles qui sont à vie elles
contestent ce bouquin si vous voulez
c'est pas un certain nombre oui vous
avez raison il y a une dizaine de femmes
autour d'Hélène de vin qui ont parlé
pourtant d'ailleurs par les parties
[Musique]
la femme qui nous a qui a tenté se
référer dont je ne vais pas dire le nom
puisque elle voulait justement en fait
qu'on ne parle plus d'elle elle a été au
JT de 20h de TF1 regarder par 6 millions
de personnes elle a été devant Mediapart
en live regardez par 1,8 millions de
personnes elle a signé en son nom une
tribune dans Le Monde on peut dire que
c'est lui à peu près par 300 000
personnes donc à chaque fois elle a été
en son nom propre très courageusement
dire voilà j'ai été violée par PPDA mais
elle dit aujourd'hui je ne voulais pas
que les détails de ce viol soient
révélés il se trouve que Romain verle
est un journaliste d'investigation qu'il
a eu ce PV d'audition où il y avait les
détails scabreux de ce viol il n'a pas
révélé que cela il a révélé tout un
modus vivendi opéra indique d'une
vingtaine de femmes qui racontent d'une
dizaine de femmes qui racontent comment
elles ont été violées et si vous voulez
c'est l'accumulation des faits et
l'accumulation des faits de la même
manière elles arrivent elles sont dans
son bureau elle pense être face à la
star qu'elles adorent et qu'elles
admirent et en deux secondes c'est un
prédateur il se rucherait il les viole
elles sont sidérées et elles ont honte
c'est ce qu'elle racontait très
courageusement Florence Porcel là honte
oui mais quand on est quand on raconte
des histoires à leur insu croyez que ça
va inciter les femmes à porter plainte
est-ce que c'est alors insu alors
qu'elles ont eu le courage d'en parler
dans les médias moi je crois pas que ce
soit leur insu maintenant la question
qui se pose aujourd'hui et qui est une
vraie question moi j'en parlais avec des
journalistes de Mediapart qui me posait
cette question c'est celle de
l'investigation aujourd'hui le
journaliste ce n'est pas un journaliste
de consentement quand vous êtes vous
faites une enquête journalistique quand
vous enquêtez par exemple sur les
scandales hors pa vous ne demandez pas
le consentement Européa de pouvoir
investir vous faites l'investigation là
effectivement la question qui se pose
c'est ce sont des victimes donc comme ce
sont des victimes au fond il devrait y
avoir le consentement à chaque fois
j'entends je vais vous dire même ça m'a
tellement touché cette
cette séance devant le tribunal là que
j'ai vu la souffrance de cette victime
elle n'est pas venue au tribunal je suis
venu mon auteur est venu elle n'est pas
venu peut-être qu'elle se sentait trop
fragilisée mais en tout cas j'ai entendu
sa souffrance et du coup pour les
prochaines réimpressions de cet ouvrage
j'ai anonymisé son nom c'est pour ça je
ne dis pas son nom aujourd'hui j'ai
anonymiser son nom
en justice la justice m'avait donné
raison je pouvais conserver son nom il y
a d'autres femmes habitués
qu'on ne sait pas déjà
qui une fois qu'il a fait construire la
maison de Solène comme vous le dites
très justement géralisme la maison de
Solène c'est sa fille sa fille Solène
était anorexique elle s'est suicidée
alors qu'elle devait en retrouver son
père pour partir en week-end elle se
suicide elle était anorexique il décide
de créer une maison pour accueillir
toutes les anorexiques les anorexiques
une fois qui a cette maison de Solène
elles vont vers lui elle lui disent
écouter c'est incroyable grâce à vous
enfin on est écouté on est respecté on a
un endroit pour être accueilli il les
viole aussi
voilà c'est ça PPDA en fait et ça
raconte ça alors
il s'appuie sur des témoignages de
victimes de proches il a travaillé
pendant combien de temps 18 mois
est-ce que vous avez eu des pressions de
PPDA ou de son entourage ou de TF1
écouter romain Verlet une dépression
tout le monde ça c'est vrai que ça a été
très violent
avec
mais comment on sait que dans ce livre
il y a pas des c'est pas c'est pas parce
que pédiatre qui va dire ça c'est un
tissu de conneries votre enquête il y a
rien de vrai ecoutez on attend le référé
de PPDA maintenant on est rodé j'ai
envie de vous dire non mais tout est
tout a été il va vous faire il va il va
vous attaquer pour ce livre pas écoutez
je sais pas s'il va nous attaquer moi ce
que je voudrais au fond c'est que et là
vous savez les trois quarts de ces
affaires sont prescrites si ces femmes
sont allées dans les médias c'est parce
que la justice ne pouvait pas passer
parce que les affaires étaient
prescrites donc c'est vrai que je sais
qu'ici souvent vous n'aimez pas le
tribunal de l'opinion mais parfois on
est obligé d'aller dans les médias parce
que sinon il y a pas d'autres arènes
médiatique que la reine médiatique mais
là je pense qu'il faudrait surtout qu'il
y ait des canons prescrits qui soient
mis au jour et qu'en fin cet homme soit
jugé pour le moment il est présumé alors
innocent on a des extraits du livre qui
sont assez incroyable d'abord on va
parler de la relation toxique entre PPDA
et Claire Chazal c'est vrai que moi
j'avais oublié qu'ils étaient ensemble
les pédales avec leur cha à l'époque et
de stars du JT TF1 on découvre une scène
incroyable alors qu'elle se lasse de sa
relation avec PPDA et ses infidélités
Claire Chazal décide de rompre par
jalousie il va alors se venger d'une
manière incroyable je vous dis un
extrait des boules dans le bureau de
cache à la TF1 elle est absone il est
absente il déboutonne la braguette de
son pantalon sort son sexe avec Foug et
urine sur la moquette et sur le canapé
il souille ce cocon blanc raffiné calme
le week-end la présentatrice aime se
prélasser sur son divan avant d'aller à
l'antenne voilà ce genre de personnage
c'est-à-dire au fond quand vous lui
échappez il vous pisse dessus en fait
voilà alors c'est pas arrêté là il faut
savoir maculer le bureau de Claire
Chazal PPDA seront chez elle à deux pas
de la Tour Eiffel il a la clé il entre
dans l'appartement armée d'une paire de
ciseaux elle est toujours absente ils
fonce dans la suite parentale ouvre le
dressing et la serre ces vestes de haute
couture prêtée par Dior et Chanel pour
la présentation c'est quelqu'un qui ne
supporte pas qu'on lui résiste c'est
quelqu'un qui ne supporte pas qu'on lui
échappe c'est effectivement typiquement
le prédateur dans toute son horreur
alors on apprend aussi on a parlé hier
que PPD avait un carnet noir avec un
nombre incalculable de prénoms féminins
dans cette personne le je cite alors le
livre cette personne qui ne souhaite pas
être citer avait repéré que le
journaliste portait toujours sur lui ou
dans sa sacoche en cuir un mystérieux
carnet noir curieuse un soir elle
l'avait ouvert et découvert à la fin de
ce calepin une liste avec des prénoms de
femmes rarement suivies d'un nom de
famille des lignes et des lignes sans
commentaire mais avec pour chacune un
numéro de portable en numéro de fixe
avec une adresse le code d'entrée le
bâtiment l'étage oui mais c'était ça et
quand romain Verlet raconte aussi
comment au fond il y avait tout un
système qui ne semble pas voir parce
qu'en fait il fallait lui fournir entre
entre guillemets sa chair fraîche tous
les soirs et que parfois il fallait
fournir deux femmes différentes après le
20 heures et que c'était comme ça et que
tout le monde faisait semblant de ne pas
voir alors que tout le monde savait plus
ou moins quand même que ces jeunes
femmes allaient à l'abattoir dans ce
bureau de sinistre réputation qu'il
permet à clé et tout ça sous l'oeil en
plus parce que le détail sordide par
excellence et qu'il avait une photo
énorme de sa fille anorexique dans son
bureau et il violait les femmes sous les
yeux de sa fille l'une d'elle décrit
d'ailleurs un viol sous la grande photo
de soleil qui était accroché dans le
bureau de pépédia qu'un jour après sa
mort elle explique le jour de la mort de
sa fille Solène il m'a appelé par
téléphone pour m'annoncer sa mort il m'a
proposé de revenir assister à un second
JT si je le voulais j'ai accepté je me
suis senti piégé extrêmement mal à
l'aise je me suis dit qu'il ne pouvait
rien m'arriver car j'avais l'âge de sa
fille qui venait de mourir je détaille
sordide et révélé 26 ans plus tard par
une femme qui accuse PPDA de l'avoir
violée dans son bureau sous le portrait
de sa fille c'est sûr vous nous disiez
enfin dans vous révéler vous dénoncer
aussi entre autres bien sûr s'il y a
beaucoup énormément de choses dans le
livre l'omerta qui régnait autour de
PPDA une des personnes qui témoignent
dans le livre explique au sujet de la
tour TF1 cette tour est ronde immense
imposante elle symbolise la
toute-puissance du roi PPDA c'est aussi
la tour de l'omerta je suis en colère
contre TF1 pour son silence passé pour
son silence aujourd'hui
et Romain vers lui explique d'ailleurs
au Parisien avoir lui-même fait
l'expérience de cette omerta je connais
beaucoup d'anciens TF1 qui m'envoient
des SMS mais reste planqué la société ne
veut pas s'emparer de l'affaire PPDA car
elle nous dérange tous ce silence le
contribue pas ce que d'autres femmes se
fasse connaître en quelque sorte le
silence des anciens protège PPDA ah oui
et puis je peux vous dire qu'il y a
aussi beaucoup aujourd'hui de patron de
presse de gens très puissants dans les
médias qui ont été formés par PPDA et
qui n'ont pas envie d'en dire du mal qui
n'ont pas envie de revenir sur cette
affaire et qui préfèrent se taire
d'accord aujourd'hui il y a des pages
passionnantes justement sur tous les
gens encore vivants mais de TF1 à
l'époque et leur rôle ce qu'il savait ce
qui ne savait pas le le la description
très précise du bureau avec ces gens
autour effectivement lisant ces pages on
se dit ce n'est pas possible il savait
et ils se sont tue moi c'est ce que j'ai
tiré du livre c'est que le le côté
narcissique toute puissance avait
déteint sur les autres qui n'ont pas osé
dire mais ils savaient oui mais il y
avait quelque chose de on ne touchait
pas au roi il était tout puissant il
choisissait des femmes qui l'avait entre
guillemets sur lesquels il avait un
droit de cuissage comme on disait avant
et en fait c'était au fond elles
viennent elles cherchent ça parce que
c'est ça que vous dise une partie même
des femmes elles cherchait ça elles en
avaient envie il était tout puissant etc
pas une seule seconde à se mettre à la
place des victimes pas une seule seconde
elle se disent elles ont un peu
d'empathie pour ses gamines qui arrivent
qui sont anorexique qui sont jeunes qui
sont éblouis par ce mec pas une de ces
femmes qui entourent PPDA ne disent ne
dit attention la seule qui fait
attention c'est l'une des patrons du de
des stages d'une grande école qui
n'envoyait pas de stagiaires femmes
à TF1 en disant non non jamais jamais de
femme auprès de PPDA c'est trop c'est
trop dangereux
pour lui autour de lui pour travailler à
TF1 ne prenez pas des femmes trop minces
il les aiment prenaient des femmes
fortes c'est surréaliste incroyable et
Romain Verlet c'est aussi plongé dans la
lecture de ses propres ouvrage à PPDA ça
qui est glaçante parce qu'en fait on se
rend compte qu'il raconte tout il
raconte tous ses fantasmes d'abord il
raconte ses fantasmes sur les très
jeunes femmes
les romans qu'il a écrit il raconte même
les fantasmes qui l'a sur sa propre
fille qui s'est suicidé alors disant je
regarde c'est sain etc non c'est très
gênant c'est vrai que c'est une histoire
sordide sa fille c'est suicidé avant de
partir en weekend avec lui
[Musique]
a été machination mais c'est vrai que si
vous voulez mais c'est aussi pour ça que
c'est important une enquête
journalistique parce que si vous voulez
ça permet de pas avoir frontalement les
victimes et leurs bourreaux et donc
d'avoir quelqu'un un homme c'est aussi
ça qui a des plus à certaines des
plaignantes mais c'est un homme
effectivement qui c'est plongé pendant
des mois durant sur tous ces entretiens
qui a montré qu'elle était le système de
PPDA et qu'il a mis au jour mais il n'y
a pas que le rapport à la sexualité qui
est pathologique a le rapport à l'argent
il y a il est dans des dans des
scandales aristophiles où on voit qu'une
espèce de pyramide de Ponzi sur des
oeuvres d'art et sur des livres anciens
il est d'une radinerie épouvantable il y
a ça il y a son bidonnage sur
l'interview Castro c'est il y a son
plagiat il a écrit il était plagiaire
donc c'est quand même un personnage
incroyablement gênant à tout point de
vue et qu'on en censé c'est ce que vous
disiez Cyril c'est qu'à la voix il était
on savait qu'il était plagiaire on
savait qu'il avait bidonné ses
interviews on savait qu'il était au
moins très limite avec les femmes et
pour
de PPDA en tout cas c'est une question
qu'on peut tous se poser c'est au fond
laisser PPD en place à ranger beaucoup
de gens et donc on l'a laissé en place
des années durant